[Music]
our own cooking confidence coach nanny
bobby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment and today she's teaching us some
method cooking tidbits it's great to
have you on the show thank you it's
great to be here and with you yeah your
instagram by the way you're an amazing
social media follower you drop in
nuggets all the time right you're gonna
do that for us today right we are
because we have a series on instagram
called nanny bubbe tidbits and so i took
a few of the best most favorite things
that we get asked about and brought them
here beautiful where do we start let's
do it okay yeah so do you know how to
clean mushrooms i have no idea okay so
you don't wash them because if you put
them in water what ends up happening is
that they absorb the water and then you
have mushy mushrooms okay so you take
this mushroom brush yes there is such a
thing
and you brush it like that so here try
one beautiful here this is my brush back
here you're just getting the dirt off
the mushrooms what you're doing dirt off
the mushroom see when i say here wash
something i immediately just put it
under cold right right i used to do that
too until i learned this and so that's
it
so easy your mushroom is still firm as
well it's not all soggy okay how do you
cut a red pepper or a bell pepper
any color pepper how do you cut it is
there a technique there is there is you
cut into it you wonder how am i doing
this right here is the easiest thing and
by the way i just want to say that
cooking method is what we passed down
from generation to generation yes who
did you learn method from my grandmother
taught my mom my mom's there you go and
so this is a cooking method that you'll
never forget you see the ribs in the
bell peppers right so what you do is
take from rib to rib cut down
cut
down between the rib
cut down this is a pepper hack right
here is what this is and most of the
time you don't do that so we'll do it
one more time just real fast you'll see
cutting down the ribs is what we're
doing yep cut right down because the way
i cut it there's seeds everywhere i get
seeds in my peppers seeds in my salad
that you throw away as you can see
and this is your pepper you cut it up
and slice it you want it
okay when you bake when you bake you
need a room temperature egg which i had
no idea that's the case you forget to
take your egg out of the refrigerator
before baking two hours it's not room
temperature so what do you do i boiled
this water about 10 minutes ago so it's
super super hot like tap water super hot
tap water pour it in a bowl if you can
see that hopefully you can and then
you're going to take this really cold
egg it is very very good on ice yeah and
it was in the refrigerator you put it
into that really really warm water it'll
take some time but it will bring that to
room temperature and then the water will
bring the egg down to room temperature
so they act together and within maybe
two or three minutes you have a room
you're ready to go exactly okay where do
you learn all these from your mother
your grandmother you know through time
and through like mistakes in the kitchen
because cooking is a practice and you
always want to just continuing to learn
but also from good friends who have
taught me things along the way and this
actually came from a dear
friend the timer this one yeah okay
this is this is a great one you guys
yeah so these are hard boiled eggs i put
them into
schools out that's what i always say
school's at i put them in and into
boiling water 11 minutes i'm going to
take this ice and put it into the cold
water there we go and you take these
right out of the boiling water ice bath
into an ice bath i love that you know
that give it just a few minutes and you
will see that very very soon i'll show
you how as soon as they cool down so the
ice ice bath shocks them keeps them from
continuing to cook and um pretty soon we
will we'll peel them as soon as i tell
you about the spinach in the can okay
how long are you hard-boiling your eggs
for 11 minutes 11 minutes put them into
boiling water water 11 minutes cover the
egg though yeah okay yeah and into the
ice bath okay okay ready yes you know
the spinach how many times have you used
this spinach and
at the end of the week for your
smoothies it goes soggy at the bottom
yeah do you know how to keep that from
happening no idea okay take a paper
towel like this got about 30 seconds put
it over the top when you put it in the
refrigerator put it in like that that
way the moisture goes to the bottom and
you could get the i know don't you love
me for that
i just want to say the greens these are
beet greens don't throw them away eat
them they're part of what's called power
greens why are you paying for that these
greens and remember when you were a kid
you did a sweet potato in the water yeah
you grew your greens
eat these greens grow them yourself
you'll have the greens that are coming
out of the potatoes yup sweet potato
greens are just i thought these were bad
i would cut that stuff off no no no
they're good for you and we'll do basil
and mustard another day we're gonna do
basil another day i think we gotta wrap
it up yeah
okay ready yeah set let's crack crack
crack crack crap watch this watch this
like butter just right off now if that
was me i would be there for an hour no
no i'm getting so frustrated yeah i know
it's the cooking method it's the ice
bath no matter how long you left them in
the boiling water the ice bath does the
trick beautiful about that thank you
chef nenny bubbe we appreciate it check
out nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media it's an amazing follow in
online at nannybubby.com we also want to
thank chapman automotive for sponsoring
this segment so good rocky over to you